las nubes se mezclaban en gasa con el
humo que dejaron los bombardeos aéreos
este martes por parte de israel- la
escalada de violencia entre el estado de
hebreo y las milicias palestinas sigue
dejando muertos y heridos en este
conflicto el blanco también ha sido la
población civil
el lunes la aparente calma que se sentía
en jerusalén se transformó en una noche
caótica luego de que militantes
palestinos dispararan cohetes desde gaza
hacia la ciudad vieja el grupo hamas
está detrás del ataque israel no tardó
en responder con decenas de bombardeos
aéreos pero que revivió el conflicto
israelí-palestino en los últimos días
los disturbios fueron impulsados por un
intento de los colonos judíos para
apoderarse de casas de familias
palestinas construidas en el este de
jerusalén una zona de la ciudad anexada
por israel pero que los palestinos
consideran como la futura capital de su
eventual estado independiente
durante una marcha judía para conmemorar
el día de jerusalén decenas de
palestinos se atrincheraron a las
afueras de la mezquita de al-aqsa en la
ciudad vieja en la llamada marcha de la
bandera los judíos conmemora la captura
del este de jerusalén por parte de
israel en 1967 cuando durante la guerra
de los seis días tomó el control
efectivo de toda la ciudad para los
palestinos esto no es más que una
provocación pero las tensiones no se
intensificaron este fin de semana sino
antes desde mediados de abril cuando la
policía puso barreras de seguridad fuera
de la puerta de damasco en la ciudad
vieja impidiendo a los palestinos
reunirse durante la noche en el inicio
del mes sagrado musulmán del ramadán la
onu la unión europea estados unidos y
rusia han expresado su preocupación por
la escalada de violencia e instaron a
todas las partes a mostrar moderación